-You are a stud.
Come on, we love you.
-Look at you.
-I love you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, thank you.
-I look like a bad Spirit
Halloween costume of you.
-Looks like we're going
as each other for Halloween.
-[ Laughs ]
Welcome back to the show.
I have a lot of things
to talk to you about.
-Sure.
-I want to talk about
"Spirited."
I want to talk about
Will Ferrell.
I want to talk about -- can we
talk about baby number four?
-Oh, boy. Let's get into it,
Barbara Walters.
Let's do this.
-You know me.
-Let's do this.
-Congratulations.
-Thank you.
-Baby number four on the way.
Number four.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
I'm so happy for you and Blake.
-Thank you.
-Send my best to Blake, please.
-I definitely will.
Yeah, it's another --
it's a lot.
I mean, we have three
beautiful girls right now
and fourth one on the way.
It's really
making me rethink stunts.
You know, I've been doing
action movies for 25 years.
I've broken 12 bones.
I just had a seventh surgery.
And, you know, kids, though,
they beat you up.
I got, you know, my daughter's
like, you know, you --
I oftentimes -- like, it's not
an alarm clock that wakes me up.
It's like a knee to the jugular.
-Yeah, of course.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah, yeah.
And I just want to keep --
I'm rethinking doing stunts now
because I'm starting to realize,
like, I want to be able
to still kind of be active
with my kids and stuff.
Like, I love throwing them
up in the air.
Like, I can throw my daughter
Betty, especially --
I can throw her --
she's so little,
I can throw her high in the air.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Still, and she loves it.
The problem is,
I can't catch her...
-Yeah.
That's how they learn.
-...any more, so that's the
biggest issue that I'm facing.
But, yeah.
-Do you know
if it's a boy or a girl?
-We don't.
We never find out.
We always wait till they
come down the chute.
But, you know, I actually, um...
[ Laughter ]
-Your doctor said that?
-Yeah.
I just --
Even after they're born,
I don't ask
'cause I respect their privacy.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm kind of hoping
for a girl 'cause I know
I'm a bit of a hen myself.
I know girls.
I like -- I'm a girl dad.
I'm used to that.
I'm ready for that.
I feel like --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right, yeah?
-Yeah, you're a good dad.
-I feel like, if, you know,
like, history has taught us
anything, that one day --
if we have a son,
that one day my life will be
taken by that son, you know,
in some horrible way.
If it's anything
like my childhood, he'll end up
on the lawn with me
in a fistfight like my dad.
-Yeah, Thanksgiving.
-Yeah.
-I want to ask you
about this, too.
You are an owner
of a professional soccer team.
-Yes.
Wrexham AFC, yeah.
-Wrexham AFC.
Congratulations on that, bud.
-Me and Rob McElhenney.
But thank you.
Thank you very much, yeah.
-Pretty big deal.
-It is a big deal.
Yeah, we're -- I'm very excited.
Yeah.
-How do you get into that?
Do you know at all
what you're doing?
-No. No, no, no.
God no.
Um, nothing at all.
It's kind of absurd.
But I do know about
storytelling.
Most organizations,
they kind of grow
and they're built
on best practices.
And I think that's overlooked
often about how important
storytelling is to sports.
I mean, sports is driven
by emotion, right?
So storytelling can grow
a sports club
in a really beautiful
and distinctly amazing way.
So I love that about it.
Rob McElhenney and I both
love everything about Wrexham
for that reason.
-There's a rumor going around
that you may be interested
in buying an NHL
professional hockey team,
the Ottawa Senators.
-The Ottawa Senators.
Yes, that is true.
-It's a Canadian team.
-Yeah. It's an NHL team,
the Ottawa Senators.
I am trying to do --
It's a very expensive --
So, you know, I need to be --
-It's not like something --
-Yeah, I need a partner with,
you know, really deep pockets.
[ Laughter ]
It's called a --
It's called a consortium --
"consorshum"
or a "con-sort-ium" --
when you form a group together
to buy an entity.
And I -- it's such
a fancy way of saying,
"I need a sugar mommy
or a sugar daddy."
-Okay, yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
You do need one.
-Yeah, and if that doesn't
work out,
I'll buy a U.S. senator,
which anyone can afford.
[ Laughter and applause ]
You know.
That's kind of the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's sort of key there.
-Wait -- yeah.
Wait till Wednesday, yeah.
-But I love Ottawa.
I grew up in Vancouver,
which has my heart always,
but I also grew up
in Ottawa, Canada.
I spent a long time
in Vanier there,
which is a little town
right inside Ottawa.
-And hockey is just part of the
system when you grow up.
That's part of your blood.
-It's sad, it's scary,
but children
are eased out of the womb
in ice skates in Canada.
I mean, that's how they're born.
-They really are.
-They're ready to go, yeah.
NHL-ready
by the time they're 4.
-That's amazing, though.
But you could do that,
and then you're running this --
that's the dream.
-Wrexham has consumed
half of my life.
And then, the other half
might be consumed
by something like this.
I figure the kids, my kids,
they've got it now.
They can do it on their own
from this point forward.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
Now you're throwing them up
and not catching them.
-Yeah.
It's just a dad-sized hole
in the wall.
I'm gone.
-You're gone.
-Like singing Reba McEntire.
♪ I'm a single mom
who works two jobs ♪
-Wow!
[ Laughter ]
-♪ Who loves her kids
and never stops ♪
-Hey, by the way,
you have a great voice.
-No, no, that's terrible.
-No, no,
but the movie, "Spirited."
Can I just say, I loved it.
You're gonna freak out.
It is so funny,
and it's also a great musical.
It's a good story to it.
-Yeah.
Pasek and Paul
did all the music for it.
They did "La La Land"
and "Greatest Showman."
Oh, my God, I mean --
"Dear Evan Hansen."
I mean, tons of stuff.
-Speaking of "Greatest Showman,"
Hugh Jackman --
hold your applause.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
The -- He --
You are teaming up with Hugh
for "Deadpool 3."
-Yes. Yes, I am.
Very excited about that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
It's kind of amazing.
-I mean, that's --
That would be -- that's so fun.
-Yeah.
-But Wolverine --
he's bringing Wolverine --
-Bringing in Wolverine, yeah.
We figured out a way to do it
that Hugh Jackman approved
and Kevin Feige approved,
where we're completely
protecting the legacy
of "Logan,"
the way it was left off.
We wouldn't mess with that.
And I'm really excited about it.
As I've gotten
a little bit older,
I sort of want to --
really, I'm lucky that I get
to work in this industry
and particularly
incredibly fortunate
that I get to work in it
this long.
But I really want to work
with people I either --
that are either
immensely talented
or people that I love and I'm
genuinely best friends with.
Unfortunately, Hugh does not
qualify as either of those.
[ Laughter ]
But I am excited
'cause I'm a "Logan" fan.
So...
And then, that covers
Will Ferrell, as well.
That's a guy that I've --
I mean, my entire life,
I feel,
I've ached
to work with Will Ferrell.
-He's unbelievable, right?
Isn't he fun?
-Oh, my God.
I don't know -- yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-But you two, together...
-It's just like --
I don't know that you find
a comedic actor
that has contributed more to
the modern comedy lexicon
than Will Ferrell.
I mean, people are doing
Will Ferrell --
The hardest challenge
of "Spirited" wasn't just
the singing and dancing
and all that other stuff,
it was to not do
an impression of Will Ferrell
to [bleep] Will Ferrell.
[ Laughter ]
Like, that was the big --
that was the hardest thing.
-Yeah, you're like,
"Oh, I delivered that line.
Oh, I delivered it like you."
-"I just Elfed you.
Oh, God."
[ Laughter ]
-"I just Elfed you," yeah.
-"So sorry, man."
-Can we set up what "Spirited"
is about and who you play?
The idea --
the premise is brilliant.
-Yeah, it's a modern take
on Charles Dickens,
who's this hacky writer
that used to write some stuff.
[ Laughter ]
-No, that's not true.
-Called "A Christmas Carol."
And it is a more modern take.
I play the -- Will plays the
Ghost of Christmas Present,
and we actually are now
in his perspective,
which has never been done with
this type of story before.
So, we get to see this
from the ghost's perspective.
But I play Clint Briggs.
I'm sort of this year's Scrooge.
And what makes me this year's
Scrooge is that I'm basically
one of these guys that uses
or hijacks social media
and those kinds of things
to be divisive,
to divide people
and continue to polarize people,
which I think is actually
a great modern,
sort of perfectly apt
and well-timed horrible trait
for this guy to have,
to make him Scrooge.
So, it's based -- and then
it's singing, dancing, I mean --
-By the way,
who knew you could dance?
-No one, and not me.
That's for sure.
[ Laughter ]
-You were fantastic.
-I mean, it was --
-How long
did you train for this?
-We trained for -- Dance camp
was two months before.
But we trained for three months
before that with Chloe Arnold,
who's one of the greatest
tap dancers in the world,
and Maud Arnold, her sister,
and I just --
You know, I basically
was aiming for, like,
a black belt in adequate,
just to get through.
-You want to be the best
at adequate.
-Yeah, all I ever said --
all me and Will ever said
to Chloe Arnold was just,
"Yes, ma'am."
"Do it again."
-"Try it again."
-"Yes, ma'am."
Yeah, that's all we did, yeah.
-You crushed it.
It's so fun, it's so awesome.
-We had a ball.
-Get ready to enjoy this.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ryan Reynolds
and Will Ferrell in "Spirited."
Take a look at this.
-♪ We're bringing back
Christmas ♪
♪ We're bringing back
♪ Plus a ton of cash ♪
♪ From some good
old-fashioned trees ♪
♪♪
-♪ Christmas, Christmas ♪
-Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yes!
-That's our man.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's our man right there.
Ryan Reynolds!
"Spirited" opens in theaters
this Friday and on Apple TV+
November 18th.
Jen Psaki joins us
after the break.
Stick around.